[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission qui
cuisine les personnalités nous sommes
ensemble pendant 1 heure et aujourd'hui
nous recevons Fadila katabi bonjouronour
et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et avec moi pour présenter
cette émission Jean-Pierre Montanet
bonjour Je bonjour Brigit bonjour madame
katabi bonjour vous êtes ministre
délégué chargé des personnes handicapées
vous avez été nommé à l'occasion du
dernier remanement c'était le 20 juillet
dernier professeur d'anglais à l'origine
vous vous lancez en politique à l'âge de
40 ans au Parti socialiste puis vous
êtes tenté par l'aventure en marche
député depuis 2017 vous avez occupé à
partir de 2020 le poste de présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée où vous avez notamment AG la
délicate réforme des retraites ou la
proposition de loi du groupe liotte pour
abroger la réforme des retraites à cette
occasion vous avez invité les députés à
ouvrir leurs chakra et à remettre la
mosquée au milieu du bled de punchline
devenu culte pour les afficionados du
Parlement alors si on l'a vu vous ne
renez rien de vos origines algériennes
vous avez plutôt décideré de nous
envoyer des clin d'œil à l'Italie et à
l'Angleterre n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre
exactement parce qu'au menu on a des
lasagne mais à qui mystère et un dessert
mythique une île flottante à la crème
anglaise dans le dessous des plats
reportage dans une chocolaterie modèle
et éthique qui emploie du personnel
handicapé et respecte les petits
producteurs ch dans les pieds dans le
plat la précarité alimentaire s'aggrave
15 % des Français ont du mal à faire
trois repas par jour nous avons suivi
Amina qui galère allez on passe à table
tout de suite cuisine et confidence
Fadila katabi un peu comme avec l'ADN
les lasagnes avec leurs couches disent
beaucoup de nous de ce que nous sommes
au fromage et à la pâte philo ce sont
les souberec c'est lasagn arméniennees
au poulet au safran façon pa là des
lasagnes ibériques les Kaiser yaglami ce
sont des lasagnes turques au pain et au
yaourt au bœuf et à la sauce tomate ce
sont les plus connus les bolognaises
universelles et puis il y a les vôtres
les las façon catabi qui raconte au fil
des strates votre vie le thon de la
Méditerranée et les poivrons rouges mais
c'est l'Algérie bien sûr de vos parents
Labé Chamel et le Gruère c'est la France
des terroirs les courgettes c'est pour
être dans l'air du temps végétarien et
verte et puis il y a cette sauce
arabiata sauce pimenté italienne forte
que vous voulez abondante et oui
arabiata Brigit ça signifie en colère
voilà c'est tout vous la citoyenne la
député indigné mais on a trouvé personne
pour faire ces ces lasagnes alors on va
en déguster des classiques j'espère que
vous allez vous en mettre Fadila katabi
ben écoutez en tous les cas ça sent très
très bon donc c'est déjà pas mal mal
c'est quoi les lasagnes façon katabi
alors c'est un plat j'adore en fait déjà
faire la cuisine et j'adore revisiter la
les plats les recettes et là en fait ce
sont des lasagnes au thon avec des
poivrons rouges que je fais revenir à
l'huile d'olive avec des oignons je mets
de la sauce effectivement à rabiata j'ai
omis de dire que des capres aussi avec
le thon ça se marie très très bien
relever et pour relever les lasagnes et
puis cette sauce béchamel qui est qui
apporte aussi sa spécificité sa douceur
et cetera par rapport à la sauce
arabiata qui elle est épicée bref mes
enfants adorent ce plat là et pour eux
alors c'est une dédicace à ENF un peu un
clin d'œil pour mes enfants parce que en
fait je tenais absolument comme j'étais
extrêmement occupé tout au long de cette
de ces dernières 20 20 années je tenais
à faire la cuisine le weekend absolument
et avoir mes enfants autour de moi toute
ma famille et très souvent bah je leur
disais qu'est-ce que vous voulez manger
et systématiquement très souvent c'était
les lasagnes ils ont quel âge vos
enfants pardon JEP ils ont quel âge à
peu près vos enfants maintenant mes
enfants sont grands aujourd'hui mon fils
a 32 et ma fille à 25 mais quand j'ai
commencé la politique mon fils avait 12
et ma fille 5 ans donc je tenais
absolument à faire en sorte voilà de
répondre à leurs attentes et je sais que
ils adorent bien manger bons produits
alors c'est laagne catabi qui vont être
un jour déposé j'en suis sûrin c'est la
recette de votre maman c'est la recette
d'un restaurant d'Algérie c'est c'est
vous qui l'avez complètement imaginé un
jour vous étiez en en trans dans votre
cuisine et vous avez colère oui indigné
arabiat oui mais en fait j'adore déjà la
cuisine relevée donc inutile de vous
dire que j'ai vécu une année en
Angleterre j'ai un peu souffert de ce
côté-là a pu et et et du coup bon
j'adore en plus les produits frais donc
courgette j'adore le poivron rouge
d'ailleurs quand je prépare j'en croque
comme ça systématiquement parce que je
trouve ça cru je trouve ça très très bon
et donc en fait c'est une une recette
complètement revisitée façon Fadil
catabi ça c'est clair et c'est vous qui
faites la sauce arabiata et la béchamel
ou pas ah oui oui oui je prépare alors
la sauce arabiata il en existe dans le
commerce déjà toute préparée mais
j'apporte ma touche personnelle avec une
sauce arabiat c'est une sauce tomate un
peu pimentée ououi mais relevez pas
n'importe lesquel il y en a qui sont
très très bien
P alors vous ajoutez quoi vous je peux
mettre je je peux mettre un petit peu
d'épice un peu de poivre j'accentue le
côté un peu épicé de laarabiata un peu
fort et puis tout ça est doux avec la
salade parce que j'adore en fait manger
des lasagnes avec une une salade si
possible laitu ou feuille de chaêne avec
une petite vinaigrette préparée huile
d'olive pour donner bonne conscience ça
ah non non non non non non non parce que
elle est quand même avec de l'huile
d'olive de l'échalote du vinaigre
balsamique du persil
et voilà goûterz et dites-nous ce que
vous pensez de ces lasagnes qui sont des
concurrentes mais des sacrés
concurrentes parce que ce sont des
lasagnes très classiques lasagne
bolognaise à la viande de bœuf mais
honnêtement c'est quand même bon les
lasagnes alors celles-là elles sont au
thonin C si elles sont au thon je vois
qu'il y a de elles sont revisité il y a
des olives
oui il y a des olives noires effectiv
ouis des
olives en fait il y a beaucoup de sauce
tomate oui en fait il y a des capes en
fait moi la petite histoire c'est quand
même au début il voulait pas faire des
lasagnes katabi mais finalement il s'est
un peu inspiré de vos lasagnes quand
même voilà on est pas loin deata c'est
peut-être pas assez relevé pas assez
relevé à mon goût mais c'est pas mal du
tout
franchement même mes enfants
apprécieraient en attendant Jean-Pierre
trois choses à savoir peut-être pour
réussir ces lasagnes à l'italienneou
voilà alors celles-ci sont au thon moi
je préconise toujours un mélange veau
bœuf et je rajoute un peu de panchetta
un peu de porc pour apporter du goût et
du moelleux des des belles tomates
italiennes en boîte parce que ça c'est
souvent les tomates on n'est pas dans la
saison mais n'hésitez pas à acheter des
boîtes de tomates Pelé souvent les
marques italien c'est des très bonnes
tomates carottes céleries oignons thint
et faire mijoter cette sauce très
longtemps la béchamelle elle ne doit pas
être trop compacte parce que il faut
qu'elle ell soit un peu fluide ça c'est
facile beurre farine lait et une pincée
de muscade et enfin la pâte la facilité
ce sont les pâtes précuite he qui vont
en fait cuire avec le liquide de la
sauce et de la béchamelle moi je préfère
ben les les vraies pâtes fraîches de
lasagne on les met dans l'eau une à 2
minutes et puis on les met dans nos plat
et ensuite on accumule les couches on
commence par la béchamelle la sauce
tomate et on finit par le gratin avec le
parmesan ou le gruillère et on fait
gratiner un peu au four ah oui faut que
ce soit gratiné voilà c'est vrai que
c'est meilleur le lendemain je vous
entendais en loge dire c'est meilleur le
lendemain c'est vrai que
les tous les plats en sauce en fait à
base de sauce
tomate sont toujours meilleurs en fait
le lendemain quand ça a bien macéré ça a
un autre goût c'est plus rel et c'est
plus juteux en bouche alors ce que vous
nous disiez c'est que vos enfants ne
mangent que ces lasagn là effectivement
parce que ce sont les meilleurs c'est ça
même les meilleurs du monde vous disiez
ça avec avec un peu de modestie ou de
fausse modestie mais ça veut dire qu'en
fait les lasignes classiques vous en
mangez jamais voilà non parce que mes
enfants
effecis par jamais mes enfants
effectivement maintenant ils ont
probablement dépassé le maître parce que
mon fils les prépare merveilleusement
bien ah il a pris la même recette il ah
oui ma fille aussi les même ah ah oui
oui là d'ailleurs pas plus tard que le
weekend dernier ma fille a préparé les
lasagnes pour sa mamie qu'elle a trouvé
superbe est-ce que c'est un clin d'œil à
l'Italie ou pas du tout ah j'adore
l'Italie moi vous avez compris que
j'adore voyager et et c'est vrai que
voilà j'ai une affection plus
particulière pour les pays du Sud c'est
vrai mais j'adore voyager et l'Italie
est un très beau pays avec une richesse
culturelle il y a d'autres plat italiens
par exemple que vous faites à la maison
que vous préparez des pizzas tout simple
vous la fait la pizza oui je la fait oui
oui oui oui quand j'ai du temps je peux
même préparer la pâte mais oui je fais
alors je mets généralement moi je suis
plutôt poisson alors je mets du
saumon euh des
anchois des capres des olives toujours
ou oui j' c'est un peu comme les
lasagnes les pizzas parce que chaque
pays a sa pizza il a les pizzas
libanaises ça vient à la mode maintenant
à Paris les pizzas libanaises ou pizza
turque y a plein mais on voit que vous
êtes fusion là on voit typiquement que
c'est le mélange je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure entre votre culture vos deux
cultures vous mélangez dans ces lasagnes
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres plat
vous fusionnez vos deux cultures outre
les lasagnes vous faites un bœuf
Bourguignon avecisit avec
revisit je préfère peut-être plus la
blanquette de veau ah ça
j'adore V façon à ma mais la touche
c'est toujours un peu le côté un peu
relevé parce que j'aime bien la cuisine
oui mais voilà voilà les les épices je
mets champignons un peu de carottte je
respecte ouais ah non non pas c'est une
non ça se marie pas non je sais quand
même marié les épices là non pas du tout
plutôt un peu de poivre voilà mais pas
de RAC hanout parce que vous vous avez
des origines algériennes on l'a dit vos
parents étaient algériens vous vous êtes
né à montbellliard est-ce que vous avez
été baigné dans cette culture là est-ce
que par exemple enfin culture culinaire
je veux dire est-ce que vos vos parents
faisaient régulièrement des plats
classiques comme le couscous ou le
tajine oui j'étais élevée dans cette
cuisine là hein maman nous étions en
plus neuf enfants préparit bien sûr le
couscous mais pas que hein elle faisait
des tajines elle faisait la CHBA
d'ailleurs vous avez accueilli un député
qui a fait qui est né en Algérie et qui
avait choisi le plat la CHBA la soupe
traditionnel voilà surtout et on la
mange avec du pain fait maison de la
galette et puis de la coriande parce que
il faut que cette soupe soit voilà
parfumée moi personnellement je mets
aussi de la menthe et de la coriandre
dans la CHBA oui bien sûr j'étais
j'étais baigné dans cette
dans cette cuisine là et puis en même
temps ben je suis née en France et comme
j'aime beaucoup la cuisine et ben je
cuisine aussi les plat j'allais dire
traditionnel français comme mais vous
avez perpétué ça quand même avec vos
enfants vous leur faites de temps en
temps oui bien sû ah oui al couscous
c'est long à faire c'est le temps voilà
c'est dire V j'allais dire votre maman
pour neuf là faire du couscous pour neu
ah B elle le faisait je peux vous dire
elle le faisait et c'était voilà une
génération aussi qui aimait beaucoup
beaucoup cuisiner pour voilà pour les
enfants et et comme on grandissait des
toutous à dos ça mange hein donc bercer
effectivement avec le couscous moi
personnellement j'aime aussi le couscous
au lait parce qu'on a été élevé aussi
avec cela c'est quoi le couscous au lait
tout simplement couscous simple avec du
lait que vous faites chauffer un peu de
sel c'est super bon ah oui vous buvez le
lait à côté non
non la semoule est déjà cuite he comme
pour un couscous traditionnel et puis
après vous faites chauffer dans une
casserole du lait et puis vous mettez
donc le lait dans le couscous donc c'est
un plat chaud et euh et puis un peu de
sel et puis c'est super bon alors nous
on adore ça ah mais moi j'adore oui
j'ore pens que c'était un dessert où on
rajoutait un peu de sucre et ça faisait
semou avec la cannelle et un peu de oui
il y en a qui mais moi le raisin dans le
couscous c'est pas mon trop mon truc je
vous entends dire depuis le début je
mets pas trop de viande je préfère le
poisson c'est c'est un goût personnel ou
c'est à cause du du du climat ou c'est
non pas du tout j'ai j'ai une préférence
pour le
poisson plutôt poisson mais c'est vrai
que j'aime bien quand même les viandes
mais les viandes blanches j'aime bien le
veau j'aime bien voilà du poulet j'aime
beaucoup surtout la pintade parce que je
trouve que la viande est est est plus
fine euh j'adore alors j'aime pas trop
les abats mais j'adore le foie de canard
euh qui qui est très bon avec une petite
sauce vinaigrette à la framboise a
jalotte persil avec la salade dans une
effectivement servi avec ouais ouais
c'est très très bon et euh et donc
j'essaie de revisiter les choses mais
j'aime la cuisine aussi bien sûr bien
française donc en fait ma table elle est
elle est un peu internationale c'est
très varié voilà alors évidemment les
gens quand ils ont tendance à avoir des
préjugés et se dire bah on vient manger
un bon couscous chez toi je fais pas que
pas que couscous il y a pas que ça
j'adore les caillots raisins par exemple
voilà donc non non j'adore faire la
cuisine et je suis un peu frustrée parce
qu' effffectivement le temps me manque
notamment depuis que je suis député j'ai
pas beaucoup de temps pour faire vous
avez d'autres recettes d'autres PL
signatures vous nous parliez de
blanquette tout à l'heure il y a
d'autres
plat qui vous reviennent ou vous faites
pour des anniversaires des F par exemple
je fais j'adore aussi ce qu'on fait le
le tajine au pruneau euh c'est vrai que
les plats sucrés c'est pas Monfort au
niveau j'allais dire au niveau goût mais
ce plat là je l'aime particulièrement
normalement on le mange comme ça et bien
moi je le mange je le sers aussi avec un
couscous et et le tajine auou pruneau
avec une sauce bien sûr là pour le coup
il y a les épices il y a du cumin de la
cannelle du ras oui voilà du ras hanout
et tout et et c'est très très bon donc
je revisite avec le couscous il y me dit
ah mais on le sert pas avec le couscous
oui mais moi je S avec le couscous comme
je pourrais servir d'ailleurs le le
Tajin au Pruno avec du du riz parce que
mes enfants aiment aussi beaucoup le riz
bah c'est la fusion don vous parlez et
quand madame la ministre rentre le soir
harrassé par ce journée de boulot
qu'est-ce qu'elle aime se préparer en en
très peu de temps pour bien se régaler
mais en très peu de temps pas beaucoup
de temps pour préparer la cuisine
généralement on nous sert voilà nous on
m'envoie à mon plat soit dans dans mon
appartement soit je mange au bureau et
généralement je pense qu'ils doivent
faire très attention à la ligne des
ministres c'est plutôt salade salade de
fruits voilà c'est très j'allais dire
végétarien mais quand même il y a une
viande à midi mais le soir c'est plutôt
pour moi des vous avez donné des
consignes au ministère pas pas vraiment
d'ailleurs quand je reçois des personnes
au ministère j'étais au début un peu
embarrassée d'avoir un dessert différent
de celui de mes invités qui eux avait
une pâtisserie ou et puis moi juste la
salade de fruits toujours très bien
décoré préparée avec beaucoup
d'attention et d'amour je suppose et euh
et en fait j'étais embarrassée mais je
pense qu'ils doivent penser que il faut
faire attention vous vous aimeriez la
pâtisserie en fait bah parfois pourquoi
pas mais euh mais en même temps faut
faire attention non mais il faut faire
quand même non non mais il faut faire
attention parce que je faisais beaucoup
beaucoup de sport avant avant d'être
député et depuis que je suis député
moins le temps bon j'ai pris mon
abonnement quand même dans une salle là
je vais essayer quand même d'aller faire
un peu de sport mais donc il faut faire
attention quand même à ce qu'on mange il
faut toujours manger mais avec
modération quand même et est-ce que
justement aujourd'hui tout le monde fait
très attention à ce qu' consomme donc
certains mangent pas de viande moins de
viande euh plus de légumineuse du bio du
local est-ce que vous vous faites
attention à ce que vous consommez à
savoir d'où viennent les produits qui
les a cultivé oui je fais quand même
attention bien sûr euh essayer de
choisir de de bons produits des produits
frais l'idéal c'est d'aller au marché
mais je n'ai pas le temps d'aller au
marché malheureusement euh et et d'avoir
aussi une variété dans les légumes moi
j'avoue que mes enfants je les ai
habitué aussi c'est-à-dire de de de ils
aiment tout parce que il faut les
habituer dès qu'ils sont le dès qu'ils
sont très très jeunes pour aimer les
légumes il mangent des épinards il
mangent de tout et et et donc c'est
aussi important de bien manger c'est une
question aussi de santé vraiment de
santé voilà publique et on sent bien
aujourd'hui que on a beaucoup de jeunes
qui sont en situation d'obésité il y a
moins ils font moins de sport ils sont
plutôt sur leurs tablettes et donc il
faut faire attention à à à à ce qu'on
mange il faut aussi voilà une certaine
qualité pas la quantité une certaine
qualité et quand je voyage un petit peu
et j'ai vu par exemple à New York la
situation elle est quand même voilà très
grave parce que très préoccupante avec
des des des maladies
cardioovasculaires du diabète donc il
faut faire vraiment attention à ce qu'on
mange donc jamais de produits
transformés chez vous dans le foyer très
peu mais parfois on n pas le choix mais
très peu j'essaie en tout cas vraiment
d'acheter des produits frais et vous
dites je va pas trop le temps de faire
le marché mais j'imagine vous en avez
fait quand même un peu quand vous étiez
en campagne pour les législatives vous
alliez sur les marchés sû j'allais sur
les marchés d'ailleurs sur ma
circonscription il y a un très beau
marché le dimanche avec une variété
d'exposants de bons produits de légumes
et cetera et et puis en plus il y a une
certaine chaleur humaine dans les dans
les marchés j'aime cela mais
effectivement quand on quand on
travaille et qu'on est sur Paris c'est
compliqué voilà de faire les marchés
désormais sur ma circonscription dans
laquelle j'essaie quand même de me
rendre alors on vous a demandé de
choisir un vin vous nous avez choisi un
vin mais vous ne buvez pas de vin alors
expliquez-nous je vais déjà vous dire ce
que c'est c'est un côte de nuit c'est un
marsanis là on se trouve à peu près au
commencement de la route des des grands
cru c'est le Nord de la Côte d'Or on est
dans un c'est un millésim 2021 c'est un
sépage de pinot noir bien sûr et c'est
élevé en cuvinox 10 à 12 mois et cette
particularité de ce marsanis c'est que
c'est un vin qui est assez vif et
robuste parce que tout simplement dans
le sol il y a pas mal de fer donc on dit
que c'est pour ça il a une robe qui est
qui est couleur Ruby et un nez assez
floral c'est vraiment sa sa
particularité pourquoi vous nous avez
choisi du vin alors que finalement vous
nen il y a une histoire autour de ce vin
bah disons que déjà comme vous le savez
on est en Côte d'Or en Bourgogne c'est
quand même la région du vin et puis à
tout pour tout vous dire j'ai demandé à
François patria je lui ai dit écoute je
participe à telle émission voilà vous
êtes de la même circonscription oui
parce qu'il est sénateur de la Côte d'Or
donc et et moi je suis euh j'étais
député de la 3è circonscription et je
voulais absolument que ce soit un vin de
ma circonscription parce que quand vous
dites la Côte d'Or les gens tout de
suite pense au vin et je je leur dis oui
mais moi j'ai pas la côte j'ai le début
de la côte si vous dites 3ème
circonscription de Côte d'Or ça leur
parle pas mais si vous leur dites j'ai
marsané la côte ah tout de suite ça
parle ou et donc voilà ça prend tout de
suite une autre dimension ah oui la Côte
d'Or ah oui la côte et donc euh j'ai euh
j'ai demandé à François il m'a dit ben
un très bon marsanais euh il faut y
aller lui c'est un expert hein
évidemment dans ce domaine et donc voilà
c'était aussi voilà faire un clin d'œil
un petit clin d'œil aussi Franois patria
à François patria avec qui bien sûr
j'allais dire j'ai mené t tous les
combats politiques depuis 2004 puisque
c'est lui qui qui m'a mis sur la liste
en 2004 mon premier mandat commence au
régional hein de 2004 et puis ensuite il
m'a nommé vice-présidente lors du 2e
mandat en charge de toutes les
problématiques d'emploi de formation
d'apprentissage donc j'étais présidente
j'avais le deuxième portefeuille de la
région et donc on lève notre verre à
François voilà avec François voilà voilà
tout à fait voilà merci François alors
on a vu que vous y connaissiez quand
même bien en cuisine on va voir si vous
êtes vraiment incollable c'est le
quiz alors on l'a compris hein vous
aimez bien ce qui est pimenté et bien
justement un des des sauces totem du
Maghreb c'est la harissa alors
seriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations concernant cette sauce
pimentée sont vraies le piment débarque
qu'en Tunisie au 16e siècle est-ce que
c'est vrai ou
faux peut-être je dirais oui oui
exactement
par parce que laarissa vient de
tunisieou voilà et par l'Espagne et par
le les les conquistadors et c'est arrivé
en Tunisie dans la composition de
l'arissa on trouve aussi du
gingembre je dis non faux ou il y a du
carvi de la coriandre mais il n'y a pas
de gingembre c'est en 2015 Time Magazine
le grand magazine américain a classé
laarissa parmi les cinq aliments du
monde les plus sains vrai ou faux il y a
un piège j'aurais tendance à dire ça
déménage mais c'est pas si sain que ça
quand on mange trop épicé mais je vais
dire oui alors oui mais pas parmi les
CIN non non oui j' dit pas parmi les C
mais parmi les 50 ah c'est pas mal mal
c'est pas mal donc c'est 50 aliments du
monde entier c'est pas mal mais les CIN
effectivement votre marque était juste
c'était peut-être pas si sa que ça et
puis ceux qui supportent pas le piment
faut faire un petit peu attention et
penser à son son estomac quand même un
peu a un Chef français a osé faire un
sorbet framboise harissa est-ce que
c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est faux
aujourd'hui la cuisine est tellement
colorée que j'ai envie de dire vrai et
ben vous avez
raison c'est Alexandre Maia qui a osé
cette petite ce petit mélange exotique
et incongru la framboise dopée àarissa
bravo ça doit être pas mal mais il doit
être comme moi il aime le mélange des
cultures alors autre quiz une des
spécialit de votre fief politique la
Côte d'Or et le pain d'épic sauriez-vous
nous dire si ces affirmations sont
vraies avec Dijon reine est une autre
capitale du pain d'épic vrai ou
faux moi je dirais faux faux pas du
tout le miel du pain d'épices dijonet et
le miel de châigner vrai ou faux pas que
pas que il y a différents miel
franchement j'ai visité en plus la
l'atelier où on fabrique le pain d'épic
à Dijon Mulot et Petit Jean et pas que
enfin en tout cas c'est ce qui nous
c'est ce que la c'est même faux c'est
laacia voilà ben voilà donc voilà donc
j'étais j'étais j'avais raison vous avez
raison allez laanette vous aimez pas
perdre laanette de Dijon est fourer
traditionnellement avec de la confiture
d'orange vrai ou faux traditionnellement
euh oui mais il y a aussi aujourd'hui de
la Nonette à la framboise cassis
traditionalement vrai bravo la Nonette
c'est un petit oui oui oui oui oui oui
oui oui ils ont en fait un peu évolué
fait évoluer certains produits et
laanette marche très bien avec cette
confiture pour un 4hur c'est sympa avec
un thé justement à la menthe h délicieux
l'ours prospère est la mascotte de la
marque du pain d'épic Faussier vrai ou
faux je dirais vrai et ben c'est faux et
ben voilà Prosper vous souvenez pas ce
Prosper c'était la marque bandam bam ah
oui c'est vrai c'est oui tout à fait ah
c'est toute ma jeunesse pas réfléchi ah
j'ai pas réfléchi
de manière spontanée mais c'est vrai V
oui parce que les pains d'épic Faussier
personne ne connaît non non non non tout
à fait non non mais vraiment prospère
attendez ou alors vous devez le savoir
mais c'est souvent autour de la table
que les langues se délient qu'il y a
parfois des deals politiques c'est la
brève de
conttoir alors on vous a demandé Fadila
katabi de réfléchir à une anecdote
politique autour d'un repas est-ce que
vous avez quelque chose à nous livrer
oui en fait c'est le dernier repas que
que j'ai pris à l'Assemblée nationale
euh 24 heur avant ma nomination comme
ministre délégué aux personnes en
situation de handicap j'ai voulu marquer
la fin d'une session parlementaire qui a
été quand même très riche mouvementée
danse et donc j'ai voulu remercier
toutes mes équipes pour leur engagement
à mes côtés pendant cette période qui
fut quand même au combien complexe et
donc nous étions au restaurant à
l'Assemblée nationale et je dis disait
bah écoutez moi je suis ravi voilà de
pouvoir poursuivre je suis très heureuse
dans ma fonction de présidente et ils
étaient tous là on est content madame la
Présidente de repartir également avec
vous je dis l'année va être aussi dense
celle qui va venir on fixait les
derniers rendez-vous d'audition de
ministres euh d'auditions de
personnalité et cetera et et tous
étaient là ah oui vraiment on est on est
on est ravi effectivement l'année a été
difficile mais on est prêt à repartir
avec vous et cetera et puis 24 heures
après
euh oui 24 he raur jeudi 20 juillet aux
alentours de de de de midi euh j'ai
j'étais en train de finer les derniers
parafeurs seul dans mon bureau j'avais
la télévision allumée on parlait
évidemment du remanement j'ai dit oh là
là ça fait des semaines qu'on attend
donc ça va ça va tomber ce soir ça va
tomber ce soir quand tout à coup mon mon
collaborateur tape et entre timidement
et me dit madame la Présidente la
première ministre essaie désespérément
de vous joindre je D dit ah bon il me
dit là j'ai le secrétariat particulier
et je dis ah d'accord je vais je vais
rappeler et donc je cherche mon
téléphone parce que j'étais pas du tout
à côté de mon téléphone Mo j'attendais
rien aucune je n'attendais aucune
nouvelle voilà aucun message de la part
de matigon et donc je je fouille dans
mon sac et je regarde mon téléphone et
je dis ah ah oui appel en absence en
absence voilà éisabeth bne le
secrétariat particulier de matigon et
j'ai dis bon d'accord donc je je
rappelle le secrétariat et elle me dit
oui oui madame la Première ministre
essaie de vous joindre et euh et je dis
euh donc je je on me la passe et elle me
dit bonjour Fadila tu vas bien bah je
dis oui je vais bien madame la Première
ministre cher ellizabeth et toi ah elle
m'a dit je vais bien euh elle me dit euh
puis y a une seconde comme ça elle me
dit bon j'ai quelque chose à te proposer
et j'avoue c'est le grand blanc pour moi
elle me dit j'aimerais que tu sois
ministre délégué en charge des personnes
en situation de handicap et de 3
secondes après je suis dit mais
ellisabeth moi j'ai rien demandé et elle
me dit bah justement c'est pas parce que
tu n'as rien demandé qu'on a pas pensé à
toi et effectivement je suis je
n'attendais pas justement cette
nominationattendez pas mais vous AZ
quand même accepté avec plaisir oui
parce qu'en plus bien sûr je m'y
attendais pas parce que déjà je je de
par mon histoire personnelle j'étais pas
prédestiné à être non plus député ni
présidente de commission et encore moins
ministre et donc quand quand elle me
fait cette proposition déjà je suis très
é parce que de sa confiance et et de la
confiance bien sûr du président de la
République qui m'offre quand même un
très beau portefeuille celui des
personnes en situation des handicaps où
les défis on le sait sont sont très très
importants et donc elle me dit je serais
très très très heureuse trois fois je me
rappelle très très heureuse que tu
acceptes vous avez 3 secondes pour
répondre et je lui dis j'accepte
ellisabeth je suis très très honorée
merci et elle dit bon très bien et elle
raccroche puis là tout de suite je dis
waouh
euh bon bah je vais quand même appeler
le premier que j'ai appelé quand même
c'est mon époux voilà oui pour le
prévenir il m' dit n min ensuite j'ai
appelé mes enfants mes deux enfants ma
ma fille était très heureuse pour moi
mon fils il protège il surprotège un peu
sa maman donc il me dit ouais mais tu
sais maman ministre c'est compliqué
c'est difficile tu vas prendre des coups
je dis mais écoutez ça fait ça fait
partie de de l'engagement politique on
voir aussi non ils nont pas ouis oui un
peu mais lui il est maintenant il il a
fait sa vie voilà il est pas à la maison
ma fille était très heure et ensuite
j'ai appelé mon suppléant Philippe Fry
pour lui annoncer la nouvelle alors lui
il était en train de déjeuner avec son
fils quand il a vu devenu député
maintenant donc du coup et et tout à
coup je devais repartir en fait je le
dis parce que j'avais mon chauffeur qui
m'attendait en bas la valise était dans
la voiture on repartait sur Dijon et moi
je disais 24h avant écoutez ça va être
le break 10 jours encore en
circons et du coup dernier moment j'ai
tout annulé j'ai là et elle me dit je
vous attends madame je l'avais
complètement zappé la pauvre et elle me
dit je vous attends et je lui dis je ne
pars plus elle me dit je crois savoir
pourquoi on va parler de votre ministère
du coup maintenant de votre engagement
et à travers le chocolat tout savoir
pour transformer la fève en tablette un
apprentissage qui est minutieux pour des
personnes en situation de handicap c'est
le dessous des plats
oui Brigitte produire du chocolat
éthique avec des personnes handicapées
tout en respectant la planète et les les
petits producteurs du Cameroun c'est le
sacré Paris tenu par févier d'or
entreprise familiale qui a ouvert ses
portes à nos journalistes Hélène Bonduel
et pierreive de
hunin ici vous êtes dans une
chocolaterie artisanale familiale qui a
la spécificité de maîtriser tout le
process de fabrication du chocolat
depuis la culture du cacao jusqu'au
produit fin sans intermédiaire pour
Nadina Bondo
francocamerounaise le chocolat c'est une
histoire de famille TR générations de
production de cacao vous avez d'abord là
en face de vous la cultivatrice du cacao
que vous consommez dès samedi je suis
dans les plantations pour récolter le
cacao au-delà du cacao dans son
entreprise Nadine cultive aussi la
différence pendant queas fait lesesit
Joh je les P ah vous vous pesez ok ça
c'est bon oui ok si ça c'est bon ça veut
dire que ça doit aller dans la chambre
froide ici 15 des 17 salariés sont en
situation de handicap handicap physique
ou mental moi quand je arrivé à F d'or
j'arve pas faire le chocolat et du coup
maintenant je sais quce que tu fais
maintenant j'ai j'ai hâte de passer mon
diplôme de chocolat je suis pas médecin
je peux pas soigner par contre oui je
peux insérer je peux permettre à mon
collaborateur d'avoir un vrai contrat de
travail un CDI ici tous les
collaborateurs sont en CDI la chef
d'entreprise a adapté les postes
composer les équipes en fonction des
capacités de chacun un équilibre à
trouver entre la valorisation des
compétences si vous nous faites les
tablettes qui n'ont pas le bon poids
nous on peut pas les emballer et
l'exigence d'un chocolat haut de gamme
la difficulté c'est donc ça c'est de
pouvoir challenger une entreprise qui
est de droit commun euh dans un secteur
concurrentiel comme le nôtre tout en
employant des personnes en situation de
handicap et puis toute façon je les
prépare aussi
entrer dans un milieu qui sera moins
protégé parce que vous aurez compris
qu'ici je vais dire des choses d'une
certaine manière ailleurs ça sera pas
comme ça dans n'importe quel métier que
vous faites ils accompagnent pas moi
pour moi arrivver ici je me se dit voilà
c'est un travail ou tu as un vrai
salaire ù ça te permet d'avoir des
projets dans la vie plus tard moi
maintenant grâce à Madame avando et
grâce à ici j'ai un foyer
d'hébergement la chef d'entreprise
s'engage aussi en amont elle garantit un
salaire minimum à chaque producteur
camerounais avec lequel elle
travaille touché par ce ce jeune
handicapé qui dit qui parle
d'accompagnement c'est vraiment le mot
clé quand on est patron et qu'on doit
essayer d'insérer ces populations
vulnérables oui là nous avons un très
bel exemple de réussite nul n'est
inemployable et les personnes en
situation de handicap peuvent s'insérer
professionnellement mais pour se faire
parfois il faut effectivement un
accompagnement
individualisé peut-être ça veut dire
quoi parce que accompagnement
individualisé ça veut dire quoi
concrètement dans la vieour de
l'entrepreneur et du SAL bien sûr il
faut sensibiliser déjà les chefs
d'entreprise que cela est possible que
en adaptant le poste de travail la
personne est capable d'assumer
effectivement tel ou tel métier là on a
dans cette chocolaterie donc bien sûr
des personnes en situation de handicap
qui sont en situation de travail qui
gagnent leur vie qui souhaitent
travailler et moi depuis en tous les cas
que je suis ministre j'ai reçu
énormément de de de courers de messages
pour me dire Madame faites en sorte
qu'on respecte nos droits nos droits
d'aller à l'école le droit d'aller à
l'école le droit d'accéder à la santé et
le droit aussi de travailler parce que
elles sont beaucoup plus touché par le
chômage he 14 % contre à peu près 7 %
dans la population active pas tout à
fait 14 je me permettrai de recorriger
effectivement en 2019 le taux de chômage
des personnes en situation de handicap
était de 19 % aujourd'hui grâce à la
politique volontariste que nous menons
avec d'ailleurs c'était aussi également
madame la Première ministre qui était
aussi ministre du Travail et aujourd'hui
avec Olivier duopt la situation des
demande d'emploi en situation de
handicap s amélioré nous étions à 19 %
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 12 % bien sûr
ça reste encore au-delà de la moyenne
nationale donc il nous faut renforcer
les l'accompagement il faut inciter les
entreprises sensibiliser les chefs
d'entreprises inciter les entreprises
c'était quoi des aides
financières est qu'il faut renforcer les
quotas non non il y a des il y a déjà
des aides financière hein pour adapter
le poste et accompagner l'entreprise
mais parfois il faut aussi une question
de sensibilisation sensibiliser les
chefs d'entreprisees qui se disent bah
je ser je ne sais pas comment faire et
pour se faire aujourd'hui ou je ne sais
pas comment faire ou je je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il soit la bonne personne il a
pas encore trop pr justement il y a le
projet de loi qui a été donc voté cette
semaine porté par Olivier du sopt et
vraiment je le remercie d'avoir inséré
deux articles qui concernent l'emploi
des personnes en situation dans du capap
et surtout de faire en sorte que leurs
droits soi respectés au même titre que
les autres salariés puisque aujourd'hui
une personne qui travaille dans un éat
n'avait pas le droit par exemple à la
prime transport n'avait pas le droit de
de faire grève parce qu' est absolument
scandaleux il faut le savoir donc on a
aligné les les droits des des salariés
handicapés sur les droits des autres
salariés et en même temps grâce à France
travail et il y a il y a un travail de
collaboration entre Pôle emploi et Cap
Emploi les Cap Emploi qui accompagne qui
ont des experts qui accompagnent les
personnes en situation de handicap ce
travail collaboratif permet
effectivement de travailler le projet de
la personne en situation de handicap et
de l'accompagner dans effectivement
aussi ce qu'elle souhaite faire parce
que aussi il faut répondre aux besoins
de la personne écouter la personne moi
les personnes me disent madame
écoutez-nous faites respecter nos droits
et aussi nous avons aussi des choix
qu'on voudrait voir respecter donc c'est
c'est tout cela là on voit dans ce
reportage une dame le le patron en
l'occurrence la patronne qui qui donne
beaucoup d'elle-même en fait pour
accompagner c'est personnes en situation
de handicap est-ce que tous les patrons
peuvent faire de même est-ce que c'est
pas une implication qui est très
importante dans une entreprise d'avoir
ces personnes en situation de handicap
vous savez le sujet du handicap c'est
l'affaire de toute la société c'est
l'affaire de l'État bien sûr en premier
lieu de la ministre que je suis mais
également des chefs d'entreprisees des
collectivités et je fais en sorte de
travailler intelligemment également avec
mes collègues ministres parce que j'ai
un super portefeuille mais c'est
interministériel c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
faire avancer la question de l'insertion
professionnelle donc je travaille avec
Olivier du sopte l'école inclusive chez
les tout petits parce que effectivement
c'est aussi important de faire en sorte
que les enfants en situation de handicap
puissent
être fréquenter l'école de la République
et on a augmenté puisqueau aujourd'hui
on a 430000 enfants qui sont en
situation dehandicap et qui fréquentent
l'école de la République toujours des
problèmes pour recruter ces fameuses
aesh qui accompagn he
C je je je je je l'entends
mais il faut aussi regarder le verre à
moitié plein puisque si je puis me
permettre cette expression en 2017 quand
nous sommes arrivé aux commandes il y
avait 49000 ash 49000 avec un statut
précaire qu'on a aujourd'hui renforcé et
revaloriser et aujourd'hui elles sont
132000 aujourd'hui elles sont 132000
donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est est-ce
qu'il y a une solution pour chaque
enfant il y a encore des enfants qui
restent sur le carreau tout à fait et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de République à euh euh dans
le cadre de la Conférence nationale du
handicap qui s'est tenu au mois d'avril
a annoncé les 50000 solutions pour
essayer de répondre au mieux aux
attentes des personnes et faire en sorte
et là j'insiste parce que c'est très
important moi-même j'ai été enseignante
et moi-même j'ai été confronté au au aux
personnes à des apprentis en situation
de handicap et franchement les
enseignants c'est quand face à un enfant
en situation d'handicap ils sont parfois
en se disant je ne sais pas faire parce
que on est enseignant mais on ne sait
pas prendre le sujet à bras le corps
donc il faut aussi passer par de la
formation mais également faire en sorte
de faire rentrer le secteur
médico-social au sein de l'école de la
République ça c'est vraiment le travail
que nous allons mener à partir de 2000
de 2024 pour venir en soutien aux
équipes éducatives aux équipes
pédagogiques et les enseignants sont
prêts à partir du moment où
effectivement on vient en appui euh et
bien il y a aucun souci vous rendez
compte je je prends j'illustre quand
même avec un exemple euh quand un enfant
par exemple demain pourra voir son
ergothérapeute son
psychologue son orthophoniste au sein de
l'école de la République ben vous évitez
déjà pour cet enfant plusieurs
transports dans la semaine vous soulagez
également les parents les parents qui
sont dans une grande détresse parfois
parce que eux aussi doivent concilier la
vie de cet enfant et leur vie
professionnelle et très souvent ce sont
des mamans seul qui sont confrontés à
cette situation et qui sont parfois
obligés d'arrêter de travailler pour
pouvoir accompagner l'enfant donc je
pense que là euh il y a une nouvelle de
nouvelles attentes un nouveau défi et je
mettrai toute mon énergie avec bien sûr
euh le ministre Atal qui est vraiment
prêt à travailler nous sommes prêts à
travailler main dans la main pour faire
avancer cette belle cause il y a un
obstacle on l'a vu cette je me suis
renseigné auprès d'hélè Bonduel qui a
mené l'enquête cette société n'est pas
encore rentable il y a un obstacle
souvent dans la tête des patrons ils
pensent que monter une boîte avec des
handicapés c'est pas rentable parce que
ils sont pas aussi efficace que les
autres est-ce que c'est un tabou à faire
sauter ça est-ce que c'est compliqué à
expliquer que on peut être aussi
rentable et faire du business avec qui
sont aussi productif en fait oui bien
sûr parce que on pose la question tout
le temps mais il y a aussi euh justement
des aides pour compenser cette baisse de
productivité justement l'État est là est
au rendez-vous mais en même temps c'est
important d'accompagner les personnes en
situation de handicap dans le milieu
professionnel parce que infin c'est la
socié ils vont être aussi à la charge de
la société donc c'est l'affaire de
toutes et tous c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'État prend sa part les
collectivités doivent prendre laaleur je
rappelle quand même que le le sujet du
handicap concerne également les
départements qui ont la compétence du du
des personnes en situation de handicap
et bien sûr le monde économique il y a
des freins encore aujourd'hui qu'il faut
qu'il faut lever il y a encore des
freins c'est psychologique ou ça va
au-delà mais les choses changent quand
même et nous allons avoir un très bel
événement avec les Jeux paralympiques
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
je pense que ce voilà cet événement sera
un événement très fort et il faut en
profiter pour faire en sorte déjà de
soutenir nos nos nos nos athlètes
paralmpiques mais aussi pour faire en
sorte que ils sont aussi capables de de
belles choses de dépassement aussi de
soi et et de belles réussites donc moi
je fais confiance à également à ces jeux
pour faire en sorte que le champ le le
regard change sur les personnes en
situation alors il y a une autre
opération aussi qui est le duodé où on
voit souvent une personne accompagnée
d'une d'une autre en situation de de
handicap et ça c'est devenu un événement
annuel que beaucoup d'entreprises non
beaucoup d'entreprises adhèrent en fait
ah si ah oui oui oui vraiment j'ai fait
une réunion de travail là-dessus en fait
généralement on a plus de de de demandes
d'entreprise que de personnes en
situation de handicap donc on essaie
effectivement de de de de se manifester
et de de faire de la publicité sur ce
duo de mais en demandant au personnes en
situation de handicap de se déclarer et
de venir parce que cela permet à des
jeunes de trouver un stage de trouver un
emploi des jeunes et moins jeunes faut
pas que ça reste une journée ça a un
travil qui qui sont passées par le duod
qui est vraiment un événement très fort
et bien arrivve à rebondir je vous dis
par le biais d'un stage ou ou d'un
emploi donc c'est formidable et je
remercie bien sûr les chefs d'entreprise
qui se mobilisent les collectivités
aussi mon ministère sera pleinement
aussi mobilisé et je recevrai des
personnes en situation de handicap dans
mon ministère alors on vous offre en
attendant ce chocolat éthique et qui est
très bien calibré
vraiment coup de chapeau quand même à
cette Nadine abondo qui est vraiment une
femme remarquable et un mot parce que
c'est C handicapés fabrique C excellent
chocolat 5% est-ce que vous êtes accro
au chocolat vous F la CAT ah j'aime bien
le chocolat j'aime toutes les douceurs
vous avez compris j'aime voilà et voilà
et et et je promets à cette dame déjà je
tiens à la féliciter je féliciter
l'entreprise elle a été reçue par
Emmanuel Macron et bien j'irai la voir
voilà j'irai la voir alors c'est fait le
rendez-vous est pris je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure vous avez été présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée vous êtes donc attentive au
problèmes des Français pour se nourrir
aujourd'hui une personne sur 5 ne mange
pas toujours à sa fin selon le Secours
populaire on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le
plat 20 à 30 % des Français éprouvent
des difficultés à se nourrir trois fois
par jour selon les étude c'est le cas
d'Amina dont la petite retraite ne lui
permet pas de manger à sa fin chaque
jour il faut faire des choix ou se
contenter de peu les o Ce et Camille
souau l'ont accompagné dans son
quotidien c'est devenu une habitude
plusieurs fois par semaine Amina se rend
chez le primeur enquête de produits
ORAPÉ oui c'est là dans ce Cajot des
fruits et légumes un peu abîmés tous à 1
€ mais je vais prendre ça je vais
prendre une petite salade là il y a des
figues je vais les prendre ça me permet
d'acheter de manger des légum et des
fruits frais que je peux pas me
permettre al prix origine quoi verdict à
la caisse 5 € seulement pour le tout
voyez sinon les figes ils sont à 6 € une
belle économie aminin a en revanche dû
quasiment faire une croix sur les
produits les plus chers la viande pas
plus d'une à deux fois par semaine et
encore et on mange pas beaucoup le bœuf
parce qu'il prend trop de temps à la
cuisson ça va consommer beaucoup plus de
gaz son seul petit plaisir à la fin des
mois quand je touche ma retraite enfin
le 10
là je me permets d'acheter un peu de
poisson voilà un quotidien à l'euro prê
sur 869 € je dois payer 422 € de loyer
50 € un peu près
pour
internet pour l'électricité le gaz j'ai
76 € Amina ne touche qu'une faible
pension pour une retraite anticipée à
cause de son handicap elle a pourtant
longtemps travaillé 35 ans je trouve que
c'est pas normal que c'est pas normal
pour 35 ans de travail que je touche que
ça en une journée elle ne va manger
qu'un seul repas en plus d'un petit
déjeuner pour le moins frugal deux
biscottes ou deux tranches de brioche
deux pas plus et le
café l'après-midi est déjà bien avancé
au moment de préparer l'unique repas à
partir de produits bruts source
d'économie ça revient moins cher et puis
vous savez ce que vous mangez aussi mais
en fin de mois elle est parfois
contraintte de s'endetter auprès des
commerçants pour des produits
alimentaires je prends des choses que
j'ai envie à crédir une situation
difficile à vivre c'est trist si vous
vous sentez humilié c'est la première
fois de ma vie où je me plains de de ses
augmentations quoi une vie au jour le
jour où manger à sa fin n'a plus rien
d'évident Fadila catabi les chiffres
sont effarants Amina n'est pas la seule
dans son cas 20 30 % des Français
éprouve des difficultés à se nourrir
trois fois par jour 15 % déclarent ne
plus pouvoir assurer ces trois ces trois
repas comment c'est possible dans la 7e
puissance mondiale bien sûr c'est
extrêmement compliqué nous sommes
aujourd'hui confrontés à une inflation
j'allais dire très très importante très
dure qui touche bien sûr la France mais
qui touche de nombreux pays dans le
monde y compris d'ailleurs en Europe le
gouvernement au regard de cette de cette
crise s fortement mobilisé hein pour
essayer d'atténuer le choc notamment sur
le carburant sur l'énergie avec le
bouclier tarifaire prisant le Bou est
tarifaire pour l'électricité il va
jusqu'en décembre il faudra peut-être le
prolonger nonc donc il faut voir en tous
les cas ce que je peux vous dire le le
ellizabeth borne la première ministre et
le gouvernement voilà sont pleinement
mobilisés sur cette question du pouvoir
d'achat je rappelle que déjà en 2017
nous avions été élus sur cette question
du pouvoir d'achat on voit bien que ça
c'est aggravé
à précarisation maintenant qui gagne
au-delà des
classesestes tout à fait qui était en
plus inattendu hein cette cette
inflation donc on fait face à un choc
qui est terrible mais il va y avoir un
projet de loi de soutenu par Bruno
Lemire sur comment lutter contre
l'inflation hein sur un sur cette
questionlà voilà il va
remettreourou faire baisser les prix on
a l'impression que ça a du mal à baisser
ça monte vite ça baisse moins B j'ai
entendu edard Leclerc qui a dit euh ceux
qui pensaient qu'il y aurait un octobre
vert que les prix allaient baisser d'ici
Noël ce qui est prix et prix dit-il avec
cynisme les prix ne baisseront pas même
pour les produits de Noël les chocolat
ça ne baissera pas en tous les cas ça n
montra peut-être plus beaucoup mais ça
ne baissera pas en tout cas le le le
ministre est pleinement mobiliser
Olivier pardon Bruno Lemire sur cette
questionl et donc il va réunir bien sûr
les industriels les producteurs les
distributeur pour essayer de faire en
sorte que les prix baissent donc on va
voir si cet accord aboutit en tous les
cas je l'espère il en va aussi de
l'intérêt général je pense que cette
question est majeure que les Français
sont en attente et que il y a un effort
à faire à gauche il en a qui disent il
faut réguler les prix il faut revenir à
une économie plus administrée oui mais
nous sommes quand même dans une économie
de marché donc c'est extrêmement
difficile de pouvoir réguler mais il n
demeure pas moins que chacun doit
prendre sa part de responsabilité donc
moi je j'en appelle aux industriels de
de de de prendre aussi leur part et
d'être
responsable et la grande distribution
bien sûr le temps de passer ce cap qui
estile justement c'est pour bah ce
projet de loi justement vise notamment
tous les produits du quotidien donc
j'père que la négociation va va aboutir
et de toute façon le projet de loi va
être voté donc si on peut avoir un
accord c'est mieux mais vous leur dites
il faut Rener sur les marges il faut
faire un effort on est dans une
situation difficile ben on leur dit on
leur dit et surtout que l'État l'État
lui est pleinement mobilisé et et
j'allais dire a mis les moyens sur la
table sur l'énergie sur le carburant et
donc j'attends des industriels et des
distributeurs bien bien sûr de de de
faire un effort là-dessus mais vous les
croyez quand ils disent on est déjà à
l'os vous pensez qu'il privilégie je
pense que d' le actionnaires avant
de je pense qu'il oui voilà déjà leurs
marges leurs actionnaires je pense que
il y a il y a de l'argent et qui peut
que cet argent peut être j'allais dire
redistribué différemment alors il y a
quelques mois on nous parlait d'un
chèque alimentation finalement il n'a
pas vu le jour est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une bonne idée qu'il faudrait
le remettre au goût du jour si on si on
peut dire écoutez on verra en fonction
du du projet de loi donc qui sera
présenté qui a été présenté donc le 27
septembre qui arrive dans l'hémicycle au
mois d'octobre
comment les le débat va aboutir et
quelles vont être bien sûr les les les
les les réponses puisque encore une fois
il y aura aussi probablement suite au
travail parlementaire des propositions
qui vont être faites à ce moment-là
alors ce qu'on voit c'est que c'est
c'est le cas aussi d'Amina c'est
difficile les fins de mois parfois la
fin de mois elle arrive assez tôt dans
le mois 20 % des Français he qui vivent
à découvert est-ce qu'il faut inciter
aussi les
entreprises augmenter les salaires
encore consacrer cette
spirale constate qu même aujourd'hui que
la situation économique du pays hein les
clinotant sur le plan économique sont
auouverts euh les les les les les
entreprises se font effectivement des
des des font des bénéfices et et de la
marge simplement on avec cette
problématique de recrutement hein
aujourd'hui tout le monde cherche
beaucoup d'entreprises quand je suis sur
le terrain me disent madame la la
députée maintenant madame la ministre on
ne trouve personne j'ai besoin de de de
dans le bâtiment j'ai besoin dans la
menuiserie j'ai besoin dans la
restauration y pris d'ailleurs dans le
milieu sanitaire et médico-social donc
on recherche du monde et on voit que
dans le privé les salaires ont augmenté
face à cette problématique de
recrutement les chefs d'entreprise sont
obligés de revoir effectivement les
salaires et les augmentent donc j'allais
dire il y a cette dynamique donc
profitons de cette dynamique
effectivement je pense que les
entreprises peuvent faire un effort et
pour autant j'entends souvent qu'il faut
taxer taxer taxer euh ça n'est peut-être
pas non plus la solution quand c'est pas
l'objectif du gouvernement tout cas
h eff alors tout le monde a fini on va à
présent passer au dessert et c'est le
péché
mignon voici venu le temps du sucré
Brigitte avec une île flottante mais je
me dis Fadila katabi que vous souhaitiez
en fait des œufs à la neige car
aujourd'hui la confusion est dans les
esprits et pourtant ce sont bien deux
desserts différents à l'origine Brigit
l'île flottante est inventée à la fin du
19e siècle par Auguste Escoffier ce
grand chef il s'agit de tranch de
génoise de biscuit de Savoie ou de
brioche imbibé de liqueur et séparé par
de la marmelade d'abricot donc ça n'a
rien à voir avec ça on ajoutait même des
amandes hachées l'ensemble était servi
avec de la crème anglaise ou une purée
de fruits rougge les œufs à la neige
sont juste des blancs pochés sur une
crème anglaise ce sont donc plutôt des
œufs à la neige qu'on va déguster ça
vous embête pas pas du tout pas du tout
en fait j'aime beaucoup la la la la
crème anglaise c'est un clin d'œil j'ai
vécu en fait une année à Manchester dans
le cadre de mes études j'étais
assistante professeur là-bas dans un
lycée et il est vrai que la cuisine
anglaise voilà c'est un peu compliqué
mais par contre j'aimais beaucoup leur
dessert enfin certains desserts DESS par
voilà j'aime bien la crème anglaise et
puis j'aime aussi beaucoup j'aurais pu
d'ailleurs vous demander mais avec les
lasagnes c'était un peu trop le
cheesecake j'adore le cheesecake voilà
c'est des bons desserts et donc je
voulais un petit peu voilà est-ce que
vous avez appris la vraie recette de la
crème anglaise euh je je je sais comment
il faut la faire mais je jamais faite
j'avoue ah vous en faites jamais à la
maison non non non non non je je la
mange quand je vais dans un bon
restaurant et et qu' la prépare très
bien je trouve que alors vous pouvez la
goûter pour nous dire si ça vous
rappelle vos années en Angleterre et à
Manchester vous qui êtes professeur
d'anglais on l'a dit mais elle est
meilleure elle est meilleure elle est
meilleure elle est très bonne très très
bonne très très bonne les œufs sont très
bien pochés je sais pas s'ils sont
peut-être pocher au four parce que quand
on fait nos blancs quand on les a cuit
on peut soit les faire cuire au four
soit les faire cuire sur de l'eau
bouillante ou de du lait bouillant je
recommande même de l'eau bouillante
comme elle boue à 100°r elle va faire
des œufs plus fermes puisqu'elle est
plus chaude que le lait elle est et au
four mais ça c'est très bon hein ah elle
est très bonne elle est excellente et je
sais pas pourquoi on dit crème anglaise
d'ailleurs parce que c'est a été inventé
par les Anglais ben en tout cas euh non
mais franchement on la trouve aussi en
Angleterre mais là elle est excellente
merci à vous tous de nous suivre chaque
semaine et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
politique à table sur LCP